Qu'avant même Macron,
la loi de travail du quinquennat,
Hollande s'est attaqué violemment au droit du
travail en remettant en cause le
principe de faveur.
Qui disait oui à la négociation pour améliorer la loi,
pas l'inverse,
pas pour permettre de payer les heures
supplémentaires dans les entreprises
à 10% et non plus à 25%.
Et ils ont continué
en reculant l'âge de la retraite pour nous faire
revenir au début du 20e siècle.
Ils ont rayé des cartes la pénibilité,
celle dont Macron toujours lui, dis-je le cite,
qu'il n'aimait pas ce mot car il donnait le
sentiment que le travail serait pénible.
Leur imagination est sans limite.
1 jour c'est 1 député macroniste qui
propose de désindecer le SMIC de l'inflation
alors qu'à l'inverse
ce sont l'ensemble des salaires qui devrait être
indexé sur l'inflation.
1 autre jour
c'est le ministre de la fonction publique
en roue libre qui veut casser les statuts
pour pouvoir licencier à tour de bras.
Soyons clairs,
de Macron à Van Der leyenne,
l'objectif est le même,
supprimer,
effacer le plus vite possible, en quelques années,
quelques décennies tout au plus,
1 siècle de conquis sociaux.
Revenir chaque fois que le rapport de force
le leur permet
sur chaque conquis social,
sur le code du travail, sur les conventions collectives,
sur chaque disposition à, en fait
qui libère 1 temps soit peu, l'homme de la machine.
Tout cela pour répondre à la demande des capitalistes,
des milliardaires,
des grands patrons qui considèrent les.
Droits des des travailleurs comme trop cher,
trop contraignant, qui opposent santé,
sécurité, condition de travail et
possibilité de réaliser et d'accumuler
des profits sans limite.
Ils ont donc besoin, chaque fois que cela est possible,
de faire reculer les droits sociaux
en sortant par exemple la relation de travail
de la relation de travail dépend entier du salariat.